what they look they had no bowties or no
looks like it's a weird thing
yeah what we do now Jordan will be do a
question from the internet an email they
have it's called unhelpful advice and so
let's go on hopeful vos with Bobby
kalila and the 154 million man you guys
can call me Luna I'm african-american
first first-generation American if that
helps so I studied in medicine and now
I'm trying to get a job I was sort of
forced slash brainwashed by my parents
to study super hard aim high in medicine
and now I'm waiting for the job part to
happen which can be painfully taking a
long time now that I finished school the
school part the realization of the
amount of misery and what the [ __ ] am i
doing feelings are creeping up on me and
scaring me as a child I started out as a
theater geek a musician but my parents
said nope to that now as I get close to
being 30 what can I do to say motivated
or to even live do what I need to do to
deal with my current huge debt and still
live for and live life for me oh so if
they were thinking med school and she's
in debt so she's probably in debt a good
300k if not more I mean it was such an
all-encompassing question there was a
biography that went along with them yeah
I was like let me start at the beginning
and at the end you know she told her
life story at the end it was like what
should I do
but also she wasn't in her life maybe to
just to live what is the finished med
school wait probably waiting for a
residency somewhere so there's no
there's no subtext of I want I'm
suicidal because one more time no Rita
left all these little read the last
three sentences now as I get close to
being 30 ellipses sigh what can I do to
stay motivated in parentheses to live
even and parenthesis that's that's okay
that right there is yeah suicide how do
I stay motivated to live to live even oh
okay and right also yeah huge dammit
right we should probably change our tone
no because she's sending a suicide
suicidal thought to your show it's you
know what I do men even when I was a kid
I would get parking tickets no oh my
thing I would let the wind take them
it's just money
yeah I've
put anything I know there's a lot of
stress when it comes to money yeah but
I've never really it's a fake thing to
me well that that's a good point
probably I mean this this sounds like a
typical situation where the the
expectation for what this person thinks
a good life is supposed to be yeah is
this like traditional sense of like I'm
suppose to get the right job how about
my 30 I'm supposed to have three kids
I'm going to be married but it's the the
real the real thing is and this is where
when I was in that and that eight years
ago this idea of like okay this I'm at
my bottom what if I could have if I
could do anything
if I could look at this as an
opportunity if I could do anything with
my life what would that be
it's a plane some people don't do that I
don't do that we're talking about we're
talking about video games earlier erase
it that's that makes me happy that makes
me I think you know until few years ago
all right look what I'm saying you know
fine fine what my own thing is follow up
follow the fun in life all that
schooling you just did isn't not all for
naught that will that that enhances your
life one way or another you didn't do it
for not for nothing so even if you enter
into the arts you're gonna have that in
your arsenal and it's you know it puts
you you're it's an advantageous place to
be to have all that knowledge in your in
your bank but it's also can I just say
this last thing it's just that in many
ways like Jordan and I were dreamers we
dream of things right we have we
visualize things and we want certain
things in our lives and we look forward
to these things I really
I wake up like this year I thought I
said this last week is the best year of
my career it has been like I'm working
more than I've ever have and it feels
good but it's like I've always had that
it's gonna happen it's you know it's
it's right around the corner right this
positive thing but there was a time when
everything was negative like how am I
gonna [ __ ] pay this I can't you know I
mean and everything just negative right
maybe try switching you know what in a
there's a there that saying we're new
pair of glasses you know like you know
perceive your life in a different way
because we focus on like the money and
how much you're in debt and all this
negative [ __ ] it just piles on right but
if you wake up a dreamer you understand
what I'm saying or no I'm a dreamer wake
up a dreamer so now do you think I mean
I know you're a poor wrapping up but do
you think somebody who's like calling in
is like okay basically I've worked my
whole life I've got no I hate my job and
on my job I'm 30 I'm suicidal
and then here's like Jordan Peele Bobby
Lee be like dream every week we get
worse ones than that it's also called
unhelpful advice for a reason bullabbai
so what we gave them was like an
unhelpful thing that was what I mean
it's a tricky tricky place to be also
she's I hate to say it it's different
she's a woman you know and it's
different when you're nearing 30 for a
woman than it is for a man but for me
you know I when I graduated nursing
school I just felt like I was putting
myself deeper into a prison like I was
buying into a trap and Here I am like
having my stepdad text me don't be a
broke millennial don't be broke
millennial you know and that just keeps
the repetition in my head I'm thinking
I'm living my mom's dream of finally
becoming a Filipino nurse and but all
that while I just felt more and more
like I was in a prison well you see the
running theme also is parent
right yeah my parents or parents like
tell you you're supposed to be something
we internalize it we do it that's
probably why you were you you're your
mom was white and she was single mom oh
[Laughter]
and yes yes but she was a single mom yes
and she did a great job with you
unbelievable
with what like cuz you know no brothers
and sisters you were just a kid that's
right
I have sisters on my dad's side right
they don't count really well they do I
didn't know long now now I know yeah now
that you have money you're a huge
director you know the the peels have
been very level of you but your mom
though did she
instill those cut like because like we
had Chris D'Elia here a month ago and I
remember Delia saying that when he was
six and seven years old here is that's a
producer but he would bring Chris into
the room and Chris would make up these
these plays that he would make up you
know he would do it basically a stand-up
setting for them and they would
encourage it
yeah right and it made him believe that
he could he's a funny guy and that he
can do it right it was that much like
your your mom was always like just do
what you want to do or did you go
against the no she's very much do what
you want do what you want to do yeah but
you know what my mom did she was
extremely creative so I would I would go
to an Halloween I always had the dope
costume like and she would like you know
becoming me she you know I would say
what I wanted to be and she would help
me make you know this I was a poker
table these really creative I was like
Castle Grayskull when I was a kid I was
like a cardboard box with a glow stick
and there's always like you're always
furniture or like they're all I get out
to is I was like a California raisin was
a garbage bag wrap but it counted like
you know it's better than the
store-bought shitty costumes yeah and
you know I go to Valentine's Day and
she'd help me make Valentines for
everybody in class so there was this
this early idea
of being creative and being thorough
with the create with the creative I
think that's okay
my my mom is very very different because
she grew up mostly hungry and so she
didn't have for her it's very linear
there's no time for fun when you're
hungry so she never wants to get back to
a place where she's hungry and that's
basically what it comes down to so it's
like should stay safe
tell her what used to do um basically
drag my sister not to be racehorses
because we were swimmers there were some
Filipino in Philippines the national
team so it was very like if you came in
second yeah I used to get my ass beat we
get onto the base but it's a very linear
thought where it's no fun at all because
if you start having fun then the food
stops coming to the table but now
Chelsea's pregnant and there's yes no
yes all right we have a child on the way
on the way and chelsea peretti if you
don't know is one of the best Oh perhaps
over half have come a loss right but you
guys are like such funny people I feel
like you guys are gonna do the same for
your kid yeah we're gonna have a fun I
mean we have we have a very silly
household as it is he's scared yeah but
I'm terrified I'm terrified but in a
very good way you know I was I was
terrified for this movie as well I know
it's a very different thing but it's one
of these things word so I kept going
like well if I'm not if I'm not ready
then who is how does that how does a
movie ever give me well did I mean it's
the same kids like you know kids have
kids like teenagers have kids they don't
have [ __ ] going on you know they got
they're trying to like fake it to you
that's what they used to say in a fakty
America is that that's really that isn't
a that doesn't sound like a very
positive noise make it no but no [ __ ]
you guys cuz I'm
it's basically like if you show up you
don't know like a lot of in a when
you're not alcoholic then you're newly
sober you don't know how to do certain
things even basic life skills right so
they say fake it to you make it do it
anyway right and then one day you'll be
able to do it right it's an encouraging
thing it's not like just go the false
person so people don't come in time yeah
I'm sober okay faking sobriety well I
want to thank I you know it's it's so
weird how it all works out huh I don't
have you asking people to do the podcast
I'd noticed that because I i-i've I
called you last I texted you last night
have you seen the movie yet yeah and you
responded I love it I love it yeah can
you do this thing tomorrow yeah yeah I
was like well yeah okay I was just
saying when when I saw in the movie last
week after I got out I was kind of in a
daze of like it mesmerized by it right
and then I was like I don't know what to
say you know because I want to give you
a [ __ ] on the [ __ ] thing you know
man she gave me a [ __ ] when I wasn't
doing
[Laughter]
[Music]